votre salaire actuel c'est quoi 2100 €
net 2 bac + 5 concours gérer les enfants
des autres leur transmettre un savoir
qui est en train de disparaître derrière
2100 € net vous êtes mariés accès
d'accord ça va vous donc vous arrivez à
vous en sortir ou pas du tout ça devient
difficile parce que le pouvoir d'achat
s'effondre pour tout le monde où il n'y
a aucune mesure de prise par ce
gouvernement on nous rajoute deux ans
dans la tête avec cette réforme injuste
dont personne ne veut il faut quand même
le rappeler 90% des actifs 70% de la
population générale et au lieu
d'augmenter les salaires notamment des
métiers utiles à la société soignants
policiers profs surveillant et autres
tous ces métiers qui contribuent au
vivre ensemble qui font que ce pays peut
tenir et bien Emmanuel Macron nous
crache dessus nous vomitieux depuis son
trônéiséant alors vous avez été
manifesté évidemment bien sûr évidemment
vous avez été j'aime bien perdre mon
salaire de temps en temps comme ça sympa
en plus en plus de ce que vous nous avez
dit vous avez été 80 balles de moi mais
je vous dis que ça fait je vous dis que
c'est très très chaud pour les parce que
à la fin du mois je peux vous dire qu'il
le sentent passer déjà que c'est
compliqué pour la plupart et qui sont
dans la rue déjà parce qu'ils sont
sortent pas quand ils manifestent je
peux vous dire et quand ils font grève
c'est une catastrophe pour eux j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup de potes qui me disent
que c'est très très compliqué Nicolas
vous avez vu des violences vous avez été
témoins de violence c'est quoi
l'ambiance alors j'ai été témoin de
violence des deux côtés c'est une
admissible dans les deux cas c'est ça ce
sont des humains auxquels on a affaire
donc il y a des manifestants qui
déconnent complètement c'est un fait il
y a des policiers qui déconnent
complètement cette un fait j'ai assisté
par exemple à des imbéciles qui
cramaient des poubelles qui cramait des
vélos en trouvant sa super drôle qui
peut-être des vitrines donc c'est
hilarant de casser l'instrument de
travail et d'autre part parce qu'il faut
être juste par exemple il y a 10 jours
j'étais avec des amis on manifestait
mais hyper tranquillement on arrive à
Nation les Cérès nous empêchent
d'avancer pas sympa en plus assez
agressif on attend on attend on est
calme certains commencent à crier des
trucs mais pas bien méchant genre
cassez-vous laissez-nous passer c'est
pas non plus je pense que le pire de
l'insulte les CRS dans une technique qui
paraît-il est connu ces cartes on
commence à avancer comme ça j'ai il y
avait quand même le fils de 8 ans de ma
meilleure amie je l'ai attrapé elle
aussi on s'est barré on a échappé à ça
un passage à tabac parce que c'est ce
qui s'est passé devant nous ça c'est une
admissible aussi donc je ne suis pas du
tout là pour critiquer ce que font les
forces de l'ordre on en parlait tout à
l'heure tous les deux en plus il y a des
gens bien partout il y a des abrutis
partout il y a des profs complètement
débiles il y a des flics qui sont
débiles il y a des soignants débiles et
sadiques en fait tout ce que vous pouvez
imaginer mais n'empêche qu'on ait des
métiers utiles et on doit marcher main
dans la main parce que la réforme des
retraites elle nous démolit tous elle
démolit tous les salariés du pays le
fait qu'on augmente pas les salaires
massivement des profs des soignants des
flics est une catastrophe parce que ça
fait que les gens ne veulent plus faire
ses métiers les gens ne veulent plus
être prof aujourd'hui les gens ne
veulent plus être flics les gens ne
veulent plus être soignants les
conditions de travail sont extrêmement
dégradées
côté discipline faut imaginer écoutez
salaire ça compte l'argent c'est pas on
fait pas ce métier pour l'argent mais
c'est pas une raison mais c'est pas une
raison pour être sous payé il y a un
moment où il faut être logique un pays
doit respecter les services publics tout
bêtement alors Nicolas merci on est
Perrine qui est à côté de vous qui est
fan de policier ce soir vous allez
représenter votre mari plus gommagement
les familles des forces de lent votre
mari il est actuellement sur le terrain
oui il est engagé sur le terrain alors
lui il est plutôt en bac mais il y a
certaines bagues qui ont été engagées
effectivement sur les manifestations
pour prêter main forte aux effectifs
interpellant donc il a quand il rentre
en ce moment il vous dit quoi bah que la
situation allait réintante elle est
dramatique on a des rappels de nos
hommes et nos femmes pour pouvoir
assurer ces manifestations là faut se
dire que on est au bout de six jours de
manifestations sauvages qui se
transforment en attroupement et qui se
transforme souvent en violence urbaine
avec des tirs d'engins incendiaires de
cocktail Molotov des jets de de des
mortiers d'artifice des jettes pavés on
a vu une policière c'est s'écrouler
littéralement sous un pavé malgré les
protections c'est une violence inouïe il
y a certains incendies qui maintenant se
propagent même à des immeubles
d'habitation hier soir la DOPC donc la
direction d'ordre public des la
circulation
laissez effectifs ont mis en sécurité
plus de 20 personnes à la suite d'un
incendie parce que ils se sont propagés
parce qu'il y avait des incendies de
poubelles etc aujourd'hui c'est
énormément de d'heures de fait en ce
moment on a une compagnie de CRS qui a
fait plus de 24 heures d'engagement 24
heures d'engagement c'est énorme elles
sont plus violentes que les autres les
manifestations de plus en plus violentes
on a connu les gilets jaunes moi j'aime
mon compagnon a été à ce moment là sur
les manifestations et on avait déjà
assisté à un accroissement de la
violence à un accroissement des menaces
même hors du travail parce que
maintenant un fixe ça se fait suivre ça
se fait comme on dit VUL
quand il rentre chez lui c'est des
menaces sur nos familles c'est des
menaces sur moi-même sur ce sont des
injures quotidiennes et aujourd'hui oui
c'est de plus en violant non
j'avais peur quand il part évidemment
que j'ai peur quand il part évidemment
que j'ai peur quand il part parce qu'on
est même pas sûr qu'il va pouvoir
rentrer entier vous avez plus de 394
policiers qui ont été blessés sur ces
manifestations comment ne pas avoir peur
et ce qui vous dit quand
est-ce qu'il est angoissé ce qu'il dit
j'ai envie d'arrêter ce travail ce qui
lui est passé par la tête d'arrêter un
moment
ça traverse parfois l'idée mais les
valeurs qui ont poussé à s'engager dans
la police nationale
est-ce qu'il est d'accord avec les
manifestants la majorité de la
population est d'accord avec les
population
un autre métier serait descendu dans la
rue mais en fait les policiers sont
descendus dans la rue les syndicats ont
manifesté dès les premiers jours de
manifestations contre cette réforme des
retraites il y a 70% de la population
les policiers font partie de ces 70% de
la population qui sont contre cette
réforme des retraites évidemment
on va reparler dans un instant Galéa qui
est avec nous elle est étudiante
psychologie et porteuse de handicap
moteur tu dois te déplacer constamment
en fauteuil roulant électrique si tu es
avec nous ce soir c'est pour sonner
l'alerte parce que je vous dis les
grèves aussi tout ce qui se passe en
France à cause de ça tu ne peux plus
sortir de chez toi tu n'es pas la seule
on va regarder ton déplacement regarder
en fauteuil dans Paris regarde et ça
c'est incroyable regarde
en ce moment merci
c'est ton quotidien je pense que les
images elles parlent d'elles-mêmes c'est
dramatique
je peux plus tu es obligé de rouler sur
la chaussée
les voitures arrivent tout droit devant
moi en fait
tu sais c'est un truc de fou là quand on
voit parce que je vous jure ça on n'y
pense pas que ce soit je voulais
vraiment vous alerter là-dessus vous
alerter toutes les personnes qui nous
regardent ça mais je vous le dis je vous
rendez pas compte pour les personnes en
situation de handicap parce qu'il se
passe c'est catastrophique voilà je vous
dis c'est catastrophique et non voyons
les personnes handicap moteur tu t'es
déjà retrouvé coincé
arrive presque tous les jours mais ça
date pas d'aujourd'hui il y a toujours
un problème avec les bus
soit ils ont une heure et demie soit les
ascenseurs RER ne fonctionne pas il
fonctionne une fois sur deux soit il y a
pas de taxi avec rampe d'accès
disponibles et là ça c'est vraiment
vraiment empiré et j'ai des situations
où je suis vraiment en danger et je peux
vous raconter une anecdote je sortais de
ma fac dans le 7e
jeudi soir et donc je ne trouve aucun
bus parce qu'il y a une manifestation et
je ne trouve pas de taxi avec Wanda
d'accès disponible j'appelle un uber et
le monsieur voulait pas me prendre au
début parce qu'il avait peur et je l'ai
supplié parce que j'avais pas d'autres
moyens chez moi
au final il a été quoi il avait peur de
me prendre parce que son son véhicule
n'est pas adapté pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite et il y avait pas de
rampe d'accès du coup il a dû appeler un
restaurateur qui a bien voulu me porter
ils m'ont porté en parlait bras en
parlait jambes et on a dû arrêter la
circulation pour pouvoir me rentrer dans
la voiture j'ai mis une heure et demie à
rentrer chez moi
à un moment donné je suis pas là pour
contester la réforme de retraite ni les
grèves mais il faut que des actions
soient faites parce que je suis pas la
seule dans ce cas et je suis là pour
porter porter la voix des personnes à
mobilités
à 21h02 tu viens un véritable cauchemar
alors que je vous dis d'habitude je sors
je suis très active je veux dire comme
je l'ai je l'ai indiqué j'ai fait mes
études à New York
mais là je peux plus je peux plus alors
qu'avant je prenais l'avion j'allais de
partout et là pour une réforme je suis
bloquée est-ce que vous pouvez imaginer
le drame
[Musique]
parce que un accident c'est vite arrivé
on attend quoi pour pour faire quelque
chose on attend qu'un drame se passe
j'ai 25 ans j'ai une vie devant moi si
c'est vraiment dommage
témoignage est vraiment très très fort
j'espère que ça sert à bouger les choses
ça fait ça fait combien de temps donc là
ça dure depuis quoi depuis
la situation elle a toujours été comme
ça je peux même il y a en 2019 il y
avait
il y avait pas de bus disponible je
sortais de mon kinésithérapeute dans le
12e je voulais prendre le RER pour
rentrer chez moi l'ascenseur marche pas
il y a pas de bus donc le seul moyen que
j'avais c'était de mettre en danger et
de prendre des escalators il y a un
monsieur qui a bien voulu m'aider et
évidemment ça n'a pas loupé j'ai des
gringolé les 20 marches j'ai atterré à
l'hôpital et le médecin m'a dit que
j'avais fait une chute mortelle j'aurais
pu laisser ma vie alors on va on va
revenir aussi sur le sujet des lames et
moi je voudrais montrer aussi des images
des images de CRS qui sont prennent un
SDF je sais pas si vous avez vu ces
images j'aimerais vous faire réagir
dessus parce que ça vraiment on a tous
vu cette image qui est une extrême
violence regardez
[Applaudissements]
là
ça te fait rire maintenant
c'est quoi ça
particulièrement venant d'un marin
pêcheur en son vous l'avez vu ça aussi
regardé
[Musique]
dans l'établissement de restauration
rapide on la regarde ensemble regarde
[Musique]
quand vous voyez ça vous êtes fan de
policiers qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce
que vous lui dites
que malheureusement on a des situations
qui qui interpellent qui sont choquantes
qui sont souvent incompréhensibles c'est
pour ça qu'il y a des enquêtes qui sont
diligentées alors je ne sais pas pour
ces trois affaires là je sais qu'il y en
a certaines qui sont en cours d'ailleurs
mais celle-ci est-ce qu'elles ont été
diligentes ou non je tiens à rappeler
aux citoyens qui a toujours la
plateforme igpn qui est ouvert 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7 on peut faire des
signalements je me permets de le
préciser parce que c'est important pour
les gens qui se sentent soit violentés
agressés ou même parfois pour d'autres
faits des faits de racisme ce genre de
choses donc effectivement il y a des
moyens de recours il y a des enquêtes
qui sont en cours et évidemment dès lors
qu'il y a des manquements manifestes non
seulement la déontologie
il y a des sanctions qui peuvent être
prononcées ces sanctions elles sont
importantes il y a des révocations
possibles il y a la mise en cause aussi
de la hiérarchie qui va être aussi c'est
intéressant parce que là quand vous avez
une compagnie complète qui est présente
c'est intéressant de se poser la
question de la hiérarchie
vous avez quelques exemples de quelques
individus vous avez 150000 policiers
vous pensez que les 150 000 policiers
ils ont ils aiment se battre vous pensez
que les gens qui rentrent dans la police
pour protéger et servir les citoyens ils
aiment se battre contre les citoyens non
ça c'est pas l'objectif par contre
effectivement quand il y a des
manquements qui sont manifestes quand il
y a ce genre de situation qui interloque
effectivement moi je réponds juste par
une seule vraie réponse la justice doit
passer et ceux qui n'ont rien à [__]
dans la police nationale et je le dis
très clairement rien à [__] là il y a
pas toujours une caméra mais il y a pas
besoin d'une caméra
pas besoin
encore heureux que vous avez la
possibilité d'aller non seulement
déposer plainte mais également de faire
des signalements heureusement il y a
d'autres affaires qui sont en cours
heureusement il y a pas que là où vous
avez une caméra heureusement oui Perrine
bien entendu il faut pas généraliser
mais sur votre compagnon parfois en ce
moment-là on sait que les forces de
l'ordre sont à bout et ce qui vous dit
on est tellement épuisés que parfois on
fait des erreurs on est plus violent
qu'il ne faudrait on en peut plus et
donc il y a des risques moi j'ai pas eu
ce retour là de la part de mon compagnon
parce que comme je l'ai dit il est un
policier en bac c'est pas forcément le
même travail que sur du maintien de
l'ordre par contre effectivement quand
vous avez une compagnie de CRS qui est
engagée pendant plus de 24 heures est-ce
que vous pensez pas qu'à un moment donné
un manquement peut se faire je pense que
là il y a aussi une mise en danger non
seulement des effectifs de police mais
aussi des manifestants parce que vous
pouvez pas avoir le même degré de
concentration même degré de prise sur
vous et de sang froid c'est mettre en
danger tout le monde d'engager autant
des effectifs et je tiens à préciser un
autre point quand vous avez un président
de la grand public qui considère que la
foule n'est pas légitime et qui a des
personnes avaient et qui n'ont qu'une
seule envie c'est de d'aller à la
confrontation avec les forces de l'ordre
là vous êtes sûr qu'on a parié à feu et
à ça et là c'est le moment où tout peut
basculer et où un drame peut arriver et
c'est là aussi où il y a la
responsabilité des élus et des
responsables administratifs qui peut
être mise en cause et qui doit être mise
en cause votre mari
il se plaint de de ce qu'il se dit voilà
des par exemple il vous a fait un retour
sur ce qu'a dit Emmanuel Macron à 13h
pénible mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
tout message pris par le gouvernement
qui est un délicat méprisant ou qui
pourrait être mal interprété parce que
je me mets à la place de tout le monde
il y a des personnes qui sont sûrement
satisfaites de ce discours là mais ça
jette de l'huile sur le feu et la
problématique c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
n'a pas l'impression pour les citoyens
qui manifestent que la police défend
l'État et l'ordre républicain ils ont
l'impression qu'ils sont en train de
défendre le gouvernement et la réforme
des retraites pourtant c'est pas le cas
en fait c'est l'ordre républicain qui
doit être défendu
c'est que ils ont été formés il faut un
très beau métier j'ai rien dessus c'est
un métier passion je dis pas qu'ils
aiment se battent je retire mais ils ont
été formés justement pour voir les gens
qui sont dangereux les gens qu'il faut
attaquer les gens qu'il faut frapper et
ceux qui ne sont pas des dangers là on
revoit cette image pardon et se
multiplie beaucoup depuis quelques jours
on voit beaucoup beaucoup d'igpn donc là
quand on voit cette ils sont 10 sur un
SDF et quand encore une fois au sol il
le refrappe il l'aide passe lever
casse-toi gros lard là c'est sur quelque
chose on se dit ils ont été formés pour
ça pour distinguer un SDF sans violence
d'une personne qui va frapper donc là on
a l'impression que c'est oui il craque
les nerfs craquent et la haine
il se peut qu'il y a de la haine qui
craque je dis pas l'inverse par contre
moi la seule chose que je peux répondre
c'est qu'à ça il y a une réponse
judiciaire qui doit passer et non
seulement une réponse administrative
malheureusement je ne peux faire qu'une
seule chose c'est moi-même la condamné
mais c'est pas pour autant que tout le
monde est responsable ou que je suis
responsable de la situation bien sûr
Perrine vraiment vous êtes en témoignage
ce soir et la pauvre lui tombait pas
dessus
il y a beaucoup de policiers aussi il y
a beaucoup de policiers avec qui je
parle qui disent que c'est compliqué
aussi avec les journalistes sur le
terrain on a vu qu'il y avait énormément
de tension est-ce que votre mari vous en
a parlé ah oui évidemment parce que en
fait il y a
il y a un réflexe à filmer en permanence
toutes les actions possibles que ce soit
de la police des manifestants des mêmes
d'un coup simple contrôle de police vous
savez la dernière fois j'étais en train
de d'aller au travail il y avait un
contrôle RATP qui est un peu en train
mal se passer tout le monde a grandi son
téléphone portable pour essayer d'avoir
une image un peu sensationnelle il y a
une espèce de course au buzz qui est un
petit peu problématique et en fait il y
a une espèce de de multiplication de
journalisme qui sont sur ce type
d'événements et malheureusement il y a
des fois où soit ils se prennent au
lycée qui me disent un moment on sait
pas si c'est des journalistes si c'est
des manifestants et qu'à un moment c'est
très compliqué de faire distinguer et
que parfois on peut on peut il y a aussi
des journalistes qui entre guillemets ne
respectent pas certaines distances et
qui vont soit se retrouver très très
collées aux forces de l'ordre et ça peut
dégénérer soit effectivement qui vont se
mettre à l'arrière des forces de l'ordre
et malheureusement il y a certains
casseurs qui sont abîmés et qui vont
leur tomber dessus j'avais des
témoignages de journalistes qui me
mettez plus la Bonette de leur chaîne de
télé dessus quoi
attaqué par les autres manifestants
quand ce soit BFM ou d'autres voilà
chaîne que les gens n'apprécient pas
trop et c'est vrai que il paraît que
c'est vraiment un handicap sur le
terrain pour les policiers ces
journalistes qui ne mettent pas leur
bonnet qui ne mettent pas qui ne et et
vraiment aujourd'hui
justement pour ne pas être pris à partie
exactement manifestants
tous les policiers aux États-Unis ont
une caméra ici maintenant pour filmer
également de leur côté et pour qu'ils
puissent y avoir les deux sont de cloche
et je sais que ça devient ça devient un
vrai problème ça devient ça devient un
vrai problème et c'est vrai que ça ça
handicap aussi le travail des des
policiers et c'est vrai qu'il est parce
qu'il y a des journalistes qui sont avec
les manifestants et qui veulent passer
pour des manifestants et qui veulent
passer pour des journalistes donc du
côté des policiers donc à un moment ils
mettent pas leurs bras ça mettent pas
leur bonnette il va il peut y avoir des
des malheureusement il peut y avoir des
tensions ions on a vu des images et ça
peut être dangereux quelque chose de
très aidé à organiser en fait vous avez
affaire à une multitude de personnes qui
se mêlent aussi bien des manifestants
qui ont rien demandé à personne qui
veulent juste faire entendre leur voix
et des casseurs qui se réunissent en
black bloc et qui vont vraiment tout
casser tout péter et qu'à côté vous
allez avoir des journalistes qui
essaient de prendre l'information et des
personnes qui filment avec leur
téléphone portable on sait pas trop si
ce sont des journalistes ou pas des
journalistes ainsi de suite
malheureusement ça se retrouve vite dans
des charges ou dans des semaines qui se
baladent avec un portable et qui
essayait de vendre leurs images journaux
j'ai une bagarre j'ai un mec qui tabasse
souvent nous aussi Léa tu as peur de
tout de toute la situation là de ce qui
se passe en France ah oui vraiment
j'ai peur pour ma sécurité enfin c'est
quand tu sors dans la rue quand tu vas
manifester ce que tu vas à la peur au
ventre alors en 2019 oui ouais en 2019
clairement parce qu'il y avait vraiment
une violence qui était partout tout le
monde était violent il y avait vraiment
un état d'esprit qui était délirant bon
le covid a calmer tout le monde
dans les faits là un peu trop peut-être
même on essaie de nous endormir un peu
trop on se laisse un peu trop faire je
trouve actuellement tous autant qu'on
est mais actuellement non je vais pas
spécialement peur à part l'épisode dont
j'ai parlé bien sûr sinon pour ma part
j'entends il y a pas je trouve encore
trop cet état de violence mais attention
pourquoi parce que les syndicats cadrent
exactement les manifestations
une grande partie des des forces de
police respecte le cadre et font en
sorte que la manif se passe bien
maintenant avec le mépris d'Emmanuel
Macron aujourd'hui hier soir avec en
gros c'est pas la rue qui gouverne
répétition quoi ça fait 30 heures
demain j'ai peur que ça puisse être un
peu plus violent si ça l'est trop moi je
m'en vais je veux dire je suis pas
complètement je crois que ça devienne
trop trop